[Music]
morning everyone we begin with the news
of a major search for a woman who went
missing while walking her dog in
Lancashire police say her phone was
connected to a conference call when it
was discovered on a park bench sniffler
bully was last seen just after nine
o'clock on Friday morning in Saint
Michael's on wire in Lancashire it's
understood that she dropped off her
children at school before taking her dog
for a walk near the river wire a partner
Paul Ansel said it is just Perpetual
hell we are living through this but it
doesn't feel real all we can say is we
need to find her she's got two little
girls that need their mummy home
Sadia with me here in the studio oh my
goodness this is heartbreaking what's
happened well it's been four days now
since Nicola bully was last seen by a
member of the public as she was walking
her dog in Lancashire her dog has since
been found off its lead close to where
she was last seen and her mobile phone
was also found on a bench in that same
area and it was still connected to a
conference called presumably that she
had been taking part in police have
launched an extensive search of this
major area around where she was last
seen they're being supported by fire and
rescue Mountain Rescue and also
underwater search teams it's a huge
operation involving helicopters dogs and
drones now they say they're keeping an
open mind about what might have happened
to her they don't believe that she's
been attacked but they say that their
fears are growing as time passes my
goodness she's got two little girls she
dropped them off at school this was a
walk that she normally did yes her
partner Paul Lanzo all said that this is
something that either one of them would
do drop the girls off to school and then
go and walk the dog in that area so he's
very concerned he's said that they're
living through a Perpetual hell that it
doesn't feel real and he's put out that
plea saying she has two little girls at
home they really need her to be back
yeah so the police don't think a crime
has been committed have they got any
idea what might have happened at the
stage you said they're using dogs
they're using drones that are using
underwater search units yes because of
the terrain of that area they're using
they've been supported by Mountain
Rescue fire and rescue and also
underwater search teams they say they're
keeping an open mind they don't know
what's happened but they did say that
they don't believe that she's been
attacked they put out her description
she's described as white five foot three
with light brown hair which would have
been tied up in a ponytail they say she
was wearing a long black gilet jacket it
has a hood black jeans and she had olive
green Wellies on so they're asking
anyone that may have been in the area
who've seen her to contact them yeah I
think I also heard yesterday that she
speaks with an Essex accent which my
might stand out in an area like
Lancashire so if anybody is discovered
service chatting to her they just need
to contact the police absolutely yes
okay for now thanks very much indeed
those poor family my goodness missing
for four days they found a phone
they found the dog
um and they don't know where she is I
can't even begin to imagine how they
must be feeling if you're watching this
program if you know anything about it
please do contact the police her family
are at home worried out of their mind
now a bleak warning this morning on the
UK economy from the international
monetary fund which says it will do
worse than any other country in the
developed world even lagging behind
Russia economics and data editor Ed
Conway has more
now if you've been following the news
recently you'll probably have heard that
the economy is actually starting to perk
up a bit at least on a global basis and
we've just got the latest figures from
the international monetary fund and I
want to show you what they're saying
this is for the global economy so Global
growth and last time around this is what
they were forecasting so 2.7 this year
3.2 next year look at how they've
changed with their latest forecast that
bar that latest bar has gone up actually
a fair bit when you're talking about the
global economy 0.2 percentage points
that's quite an upgrade because things
are looking better inflation might have
peaked it's a pretty good news story but
I'm afraid it doesn't get so good when
you look at the UK so this is just
breaking it down looking at Major
economies around the world and just how
fast they're growing in this year so
2023 and last time around this is the
forecast from last time around the UK
was expected to have 0.3 percent growth
just look at how that's changed with
these latest updates look look at the
Red Bar it's gone all the way down to
the bottom no longer positive territory
now it's 0.6 contraction so basically
it's pointing towards a recession in the
UK and it is the worst in the G7 this is
the G7 group of uh major industrialized
economies from Japan all the way through
to the UK and you see the UK is by far
and away the worst and actually when you
look at all of the economies so all
major economies the IMF is surveying
look down there there's the UK 0.6 and
not only is it the worst hit it is
actually worse than Russia so Russia
there with 0.3 growth the UK minus 0.6
it's pretty striking isn't it and I'm
afraid it's not a very good news story
when you look at the following year as
well 2024 as well the UK down there at
the bottom actually joint worst with
Italy and Japan why is all of this
happening well the IMF says it's
basically because you've got the
government raising taxes you've got
fiscal consolidation as they call it and
a bank of England rating interest rates
at the same time add it all up and I'm
afraid well it's good news for the
global economy is not very good news for
the UK economy
well we've already had a government
response to that forecast here we go the
chancellor Jeremy Hunt said the governor
of the bank of England recently said
that any UK recession this year is
likely to be shallower than previously
predicted however these figures confirm
we are not immune to the pressures
hitting nearly all advanced economies
we're still at the end though Jeremy uh
short-term challenges should not obscure
our long-term prospects the UK
outperformed many forecasts last year
and if we stick to our plan to have
inflation the UK is still predicted to
grow faster than Germany and Japan over
the coming years just not this year the
shadow Chancellor Rachel Reese said
Britain has huge potential but too many
signs are pointing towards really
difficult times through our economy
leaving us lagging behind our peers she
went on to say the government should be
doing all it can to make our economy
stronger and to get it growing they
would say of course that they are it's
only it's the only way that we can move
Beyond lurching from crisis to crisis as
we have been for far too long
talking about that with amongst others
Jacob Reese mogg coming up very shortly
it's the anniversary of brexit as well
today can you believe it do you know how
many years it is since we voted to leave
the European Union yeah I know check it
out no it's more than four uh now if
you've got kids you might be struggling
to know what to do with them tomorrow
with the news the biggest teacher strike
in years is to go ahead in England and
Wales members of the National Education
Union in England and Wales will walk out
tomorrow over pay with more action
planned in the coming weeks up to 23 000
schools could be impacted by the walkout
here we go 7 30 we'll be speaking to the
Joint General Secretary of the National
Education Union Kevin Courtney over
claims the education secretary
squandered the opportunity to resolve
the row
well MPS have backed anti-strike
legislation which is aimed at enforcing
minimum service levels for some sectors
during strikes it's clear the commons
but not without criticism from a
prominent tory-backed bencher and former
cabinet minister Jacob Reese smog has
criticized the sweeping powers and vague
wording within the bill suggesting the
blame lay with incompetence within the
government and this is almost so
skeletal that you wonder if bits of the
bones have been stolen away by wild
animals and taken and buried somewhere
as if you know in cartoon characters
happens I want good legislation I want
legislation that achieves it object its
objective and that clarifies the
boundaries of power between the
legislature the king in Parliament and
the courts
well as I said mystery Smog on the
program just after eight speaking to us
about strikes the state of the UK
economy and brexit
uh U.S President Joe Biden has said that
America will not be sending F-16 fighter
jets to Ukraine it comes as Ukrainian
officials have stepped up their calls to
Western allies to send fourth generation
Fighters like s-16s after securing
supplies of Battle Tanks last week
our security and defense editor Deborah
Haynes is standing by in Kiev for us
this morning hello to you Deborah are we
going to be sending Jets do you think to
Ukraine
well it's a it's a very live debate
isn't it after Ukraine's success in
obtaining these Western Battle Tanks the
UK defense secretary in the Commons
yesterday was asked about whether or not
the UK might um be part or be part of
some sort of Coalition of
um countries sending in fighter jets and
he uh he sort of made the point that
there's been a sort of track record of
countries saying no to a certain piece
of equipment for example tanks and then
later saying yes and saying that he was
keeping an open mind the same kind of
noises have been made by President
macron of France and Ukraine's defense
minister is actually going to be
visiting France this week presumably as
well to talk about that and just to give
you a sense of why Ukraine is continuing
to want to want ever more lethal weapons
Britain's defense intelligence update
the daily report it gives says today
that Russia is likely aiming to develop
a new access of advance in the Donetsk
region in the east of the country and it
says it's likely that they will continue
to make local games down there but it
says it's unlikely that they're going to
be making any significant operational
breakthroughs but it's a reminder of
this grinding War and the threat it's
going to escalate and the reason why
Ukraine needs these weapons yeah when we
were chatting as you know last week to
president zielinski put it to him that
you know he's not going to get fighter
jets because of the way they will be
used you said yeah people didn't think I
was going to get tanks and originally
the Germans promised What helmets
foreign
s went from helmet descending in their
leopard to tanks and he's right to to
sort of mention that positions change
over time I think with fighter jets
there's a real nervousness given that
they operate it obviously in the sky
um could they be used to Target uh
directly onto the Russian territory I
think that would be a lot of assurances
needed to calm those nerves and then
also of course training the Ukrainian
pilots on these debts and finally it has
to be said when it comes to the UK If
you think we were pretty poor in the
number of Tanks we were able to give to
the ukrainians I'm imagining that the
fighter jet situation would be even
worse given the number of operationally
available typhoon debts on the books
okay for now thanks very much Deborah
thank you also making news for you on
the breakfast program this morning
Priscilla Presley is contesting the will
of her late daughter Lisa Marie after
she died earlier this month an amendment
to the Will made it in 2016 removes
Elvis's ex-wife as an overseer of her
daughter's estate replaced instead by
Lisa Marie's two eldest children
Priscilla's legal team claimed the
document was suspiciously altered and
are questioning the authenticity of a
signature
former world's rugby Captain Gareth
Thomas will pay 75 000 pounds to settle
a legal case with an ex-partner who
accused him of deceptively transmitting
HIV
Thomas for allegedly hiding his HIV
status and failing to take reasonable
care not to pass the virus on Mr Thomas
has said the settlement was not an
admission of liability or guilt
Coastal homes worth almost 600 million
pounds in England could be lost to the
Sea according to a climate Action Group
the coastal communities that could lose
the most homes include areas in Cornwall
Cumbria and Dorset
now everyone in England is to live
within a 15-minute walk from a green
space or water under new plans being
proposed by the government an
announcement today will build on the
government's 25-year environment plan
laid out in 2018 the government will
commit to restoring at least 1.2 million
Acres of wildlife habitats to protect
the country's rarest species this
involves 70 projects forgive me
including 25 new or expanded National
nature Reserves around 400 miles of
river will be restored through landscape
recovery projects
and through government schemes farmers
will be incentivized to adopt nature
friendly farming practices and encourage
to restore hedge growth
the death toll from a suicide bombing at
a mosque in Pakistan has climbed to 83
after more bodies were discovered 57
people were injured in the explosion
inside a police compound in the city of
bashawar the blast caused the roof of
the mosque to collapse it's unclear who
was behind the attack
the Pakistani Taliban said they were not
responsible
Australia's nuclear safety agency has
joined a hunt for a tiny radioactive
capsule missing somewhere in the outback
The Specialist Team has been sent with
equipment to detect the capsule which is
believed to have fallen from a truck
that had traveled 870 miles in Western
Australia the incident triggered a
radiation alert from large parts of the
state
still to come on the program for you
after eight joined by former Tory
cabinet minister Jacob Reese smog who's
attacked the government's anti-strike
laws
speaking to an amputee who's going for
gold after rediscovering his love for
table tennis
and his campaigners worn homes worth
hundreds of millions of pounds could be
lost to the Sea speaking to someone who
lost their home in a tidal search
U.S Secretary of State Anthony blinken
will meet the Palestinian leader Mahmoud
Abbas later this morning yesterday Mr
blinken met with the Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu let's speak
to our Middle East correspondent she'll
be Aleister bunkel standing by in
Jerusalem hello to you Ali good morning
and what came out of yesterday's talks
well I mean there was a press conference
between Anthony blinken and benign
Netanyahu after their talks yesterday
which uh the most interesting element I
found from it was that in uh the Israeli
Prime Minister's remarks he made no
mention of the recent violence or the
terror attacks that has struck Jerusalem
over the last couple of days and maybe
that speaks to uh where the Israeli
government is on this at the moment and
how much they want to enter into those
discussions with the Americans of course
this trip was planned before the recent
Spate of violence and there are other
topics on the agenda that the Israelis
want to discuss for example the threat
coming from Iran but it has taken on a
greater urgency because of the spike in
violence and Anthony blinken was very
clear that he's coming here calling for
Carmen calling from both sides to do
something to de-escalate the situation
it's not really clear what he can do
beyond that I don't think we're going to
see any kind of particularly significant
change in U.S policy towards Israel and
Palestine I don't think we're going to
see any kind of breakthrough I think the
best that the U.S Secretary of State can
hope for is that he manages to convince
both sides to keep the situation
reasonably stable at the moment but he
will have those conversations today with
the Palestinian leadership in Ramallah
and he will again ask them to try and do
something to calm the violence here okay
Alistair for no thanks very much indeed
thank you
later this I will be joined by the
Israeli ambassador to the UK Zippy
Potter Valley
and then tomorrow morning we'll be
joined by the Palestinian ambassador to
the UK who Sam's omnot
returning now to our one of our top
stories I should say strikes MPS have
backed anti-strike legislation aimed at
enforcing minimum service levels for
some sectors during strikes let's talk
about it more detail should we the
minister for roads and local transport
Richard Holden is here with us now hi
good morning morning not sure you've
been on my sofa I haven't been on
yourself you're very welcome to join us
to have you offered a cup of tea Etc
um talk to me about the strikes schools
are struggling to plan for tomorrow's
strikes apparently unions told members
to keep head teachers in the dark is
that a responsible or smart tactic look
I don't want to see any strikes
happening at all and and when the they
are strike action is happening I want as
much information to be made available as
possible what we saw during the pandemic
was kids education must have been
affected by having to not be in school
not be able to learn and not have that
teachers there in front of them
um I don't want to see that strike
action happening now those kids have
already had a really tough time over the
last few is I think we should have
teachers in the classroom teaching where
possible and I I don't think we want to
make it even more difficult for head
teachers to prepare at the moment okay
so are the tactics
they irresponsible well I don't think
it's responsible for teachers to be
going out on strike at this moment in
time I think we've seen as I've said a
couple of years it's been really tough
for kids I've been in a lot of my own
local primary schools across Northwest
Durham over the last few months where
they've said there's been a real impact
of the pandemic on children's education
and I want to see is returning to normal
ensuring that those children can get the
education that they need to get on and
succeed in life I don't think we should
see a strike action as we've seen at the
moment what's your advice to parents I
mean they're doing their level best to
try and you know put food on the table
what are they going to do tomorrow when
the kids are not at school yeah well
it's really tough there are going to be
people's lives are going to be seriously
affected by this we've seen that in
other sectors as well like in transport
which we know has also had knock-on
effects on people's lives their ability
to get to work to take the kids to
school and things like that as well so I
really don't want us to see us in a
space where we're seeing so much strike
action you know it comes to classroom
teachers the average teachers on about
39.5 000 a year and whatever the
government's already offered a five
percent settlement which would take that
to well over 40 000 a year and that's
the average classroom teacher plus
around quarter of their salary as a
pension contribution as well I think
it's a reasonable package overall and
look I don't want to see um public
sector workers out on strike because the
impact it has on everybody else and
you're right it's not just on the kids
it's a knock-on impact on wider families
as well and the ability of their parents
to get to work too okay yesterday we
heard how the mod has been hollowed out
by years of underfunding we've chatted
to a former senior General as well who
told us that money should be spent on
defense rather than potholes given that
it's a subject closer to your heart do
you agree I think what we need to see is
a balance across government if I'm
totally honest I don't think it should
all be spent on one or the other we've
got to see that balance we can only get
that balance if we got the economy
growing and that's what I want to see us
focus on that's what I see a
government's first responsibility is to
defend the realm are you absolutely
right and you know we're the biggest
defense spender in Europe uh one of them
one of a handful of countries in NATO
which spends above two percent well we
could say it's not enough for everything
really but it's all about trying to get
that balance within what is a
constrained environment at the moment
the mod defense budget shouldn't be
bigger no of course it should but it's
got to be grown but it's got to be grown
in that in that sensible uh way where
we're still seeing uh two percent of GDP
minimum there and but it's got to be
done in a balanced way with other parts
of the economy like public services
um health education and transport and
all those other things it's all about us
having to see things in the round but do
you acknowledge uh that defense has to
be the most important the defense is
always the most important thing for any
government to do but I think when you
see the way that you know I was a
special advisor in the ministry of
Defense before I was an MP a few years
ago you know the way that Britain
stepped up when other countries didn't
when it came to Ukraine after the
invasion of Crimea you know as Britain
was the UK training those soldiers it's
the way you've seen it now with um Rishi
and Ben ensuring that we're the ones
there at the Forefront of sending heavy
armor to help the ukrainians I think you
can see Britain uh leading in Europe and
as a world leader as well in defense but
yeah it's going to be part of a balanced
package but I want to see is are
punching above our weight as we have
done over the last few decades to that
end should we be sending Ukraine fighter
jets well I think we've got to see it in
the round I think what we've done is
we've led the way with training
initially now we've we've led the way
with the enlarsio's anti-tacular cells
well I think we need to that's going to
be that's going to be the decision for
somebody at a slightly higher level than
me with much more knowledge of the
situation no you just told me you worked
in the ministry of Defense I did I did
but I think obviously by your impetus I
think what we've got to see is that the
people of the knowledge of the situation
at the moment need to make those
decisions that's the decision which was
made around tanks as well that had been
not not been an easy decision not what
we made at an earlier stage but as the
situation evolves the situation changes
and we've seen over the last you know
year to 18 months how that situation has
evolved only a few months ago Germany
wouldn't send any form of
um uh Weaponry at all to the Ukraine and
the question is The Duchess said ask us
the Dutch government has said ask us and
we'll look at it favorably the polls
have said ask us and we'll look at it
favorably should we be saying the same I
think we'll we'll all the government
will always look at all options but what
we've got we look at it favorably I'm
sure we'll always look at everything
that president was allowed to ask for
favorably that's why we've been there
the ones pushing on heavy armor that's
why we were some of the ones there at an
earlier stage pushing on those anti-tank
missiles as well and we've been leading
on that I'm sure I've seen as I drive up
to my constituency every week I've seen
the Dutch forces as well they're helping
us train those Ukrainian soldiers to I
think what we've seen actually over the
last uh couple of years is where
Britain's LED others have followed we've
certainly been leading in Europe on that
and I think it's made us you know it's
made all of us concentrate on what's
very important which is the fundamental
rule of law and democracy and which is
what we've been standing up for okay IMF
report I'm sure you're brief for this
one the UK is on course to be the
world's worst performing major economy
I.E the Chancellor's getting it wrong
well I think if you look into the AF
report I did what they've said also is
that they've praised what the government
have done since uh over the last few
months with Jeremy and Rishi coming in
and helping stabilize the situation
we've been worse could it I mean the
previous prime minister completely
crashed the economy what we also have
seen over the last few months though is
that actually the UK has outperformed
the imf's predictions for last year and
the oecd's predictions and the year
before since 2016 we've you know
performed better than Germany for
example
um which is Europe's largest economy so
I think actually when you see it in the
round I'm interested in outcomes what's
then this is now and indeed and they
made those same predictions then and I'm
interested in what's our economy is even
worse than Russia well that's what they
say
the proof will be in the pudding so what
are you saying I got it wrong well
that's what they they did in the last
couple of years and and I think Britain
can outperform these predictions like it
has them for the last two years when you
look over the last couple of years we've
outperformed Germany and Japan as well
you know these are these are big world
economies which we've outperformed
relatively I want to see is that I'm not
saying it's going to be an easy time
we've got those huge headwinds around
Energy prices inflation which isn't just
knocking on to you know the fuel at the
pump or onto gas but it's also knocking
onto things like food which we've seen
food price inflation so much higher
we've got that's one of the reasons
we've got to get inflation under control
because it makes everybody poorer
particularly those who can least afford
it you say that they're praising um the
chancellor and the Prime Minister but
when I was reading it it said a tight
they blame the contraction of the
British economy on a tighter fiscal and
monetary policy
that's the chancellor right that's
totally different to what they'd said uh
four months ago when they praised about
the UK government and also look the
governor of the bank of England's also
said uh very clearly uh that he thinks
that the actions that the chancellor
have taken has actually made the
recession uh shallower uh and will mean
that we can bounce back quicker and I
think just to clarify the IMF is wrong
and this government will prove them
wrong about the economy here I think so
and and the IMF has also changed its
changed its mind on some of these
aspects before and the figures have
shown that the AMF were wrong that's why
when we were predicted to be slower
growing than other countries actually
we've been quicker than say Germany and
Japan and I think we can still
outperform over the next few years as
well who do you think will be the um
best chairman of the party oh well I
mean that's well above my pay grade yeah
you've got a view I do I have lots of
views but I think will be most appealing
to the election it's usually best to
keep those views to myself all right I'm
convinced that the Prime Minister will
make a sensible smart one I said Boris
sensible and clear decision on the
future I don't think in Venice this is
something that Boris will want to do
seems to be quite happy doing what he's
doing at the moment we're making quite a
lot of money well indeed okay it's good
to see you thank you much appreciated
quick look at the papers for you here on
the program this morning Daily Mail
leads on the international monetary
funds prediction that Britain will have
the weakest growth of all the major
economies this year that's also the main
story for the eye
and for the financial times the
telegraph also leads on the IMF warning
but also highlights as well a
braverman's call for the government to
Halt migrant boats arriving in the UK or
lose the next election the guardian
headlines the imf-2 drawing attention to
the last economic impact of Liz truss's
budget the times reports schools face
chaos over tomorrow's teacher strikes
because unions have told their members
not to say in advance whether they'll be
taking action and the son has a story
about Chelsea's new 88 million pound
signing using racist language in a tick
tock rap video
Mary's here hi good morning good morning
what do you make of what the minister
had to say well I thought it was
interesting what he was talking about
bouncing back the economy bouncing back
and that IMF report and he's very much
trying to explain that as far as he's
concerned as far as the government's
concerned they can absolutely kind of
defy or gravity to an extent defy those
expectations and he said we've done it
again we've done it once before and we
can do it again so very much trying to
kind of reflect that boosterism that the
government is trying to project when it
comes to the financial kind of chaos or
the financial turmoil that Liz trust
left behind but what was also
interesting was you asked him about
defense and the fact that you know
there's been people saying you know how
much are we going to be spending on
defense how much should we potentially
be spending on defense instead of NHS
services or Healthcare and that debate
that's been rumbling on for a long time
in the Tory party and he was very much
trying to emphasize that balance was
needed the really key question is how
are Tory MPS going to agree on the
balance they are very divided on the
level of balance and they're a different
faction of the Tory parties that can't
seem to actually agree on what that
balance should be yeah I thought it was
interesting when he said zelenski gets
what he wants yes very interesting I
think politically it's difficult to say
noted zelenski obviously he's a war hero
we massively backed Ukraine as a nation
don't we and therefore it does pull on
the heartstrings and there's a lot of
political pressure to make sure we are
seen to be backing utrecha in Ukraine on
any kind of footing we possibly can but
I think I mean you're asking him about
those fighter jets and he didn't want to
be drawn on that did he but I think I
think it's a very very difficult
question in terms of how do we balance
that a kind of appeasing Ukraine but
also nonetheless sticking with our
allies and making sure that we're not
sticking our neck out all alone so you
know difficult defense questions
teachers in England and Wales will go on
strike tomorrow after last minute talks
with the education secretary failed The
Joint General Secretary of the National
Education Union Kevin Courtney is with
us now hello to Mr Courtney thanks for
joining us on the program just speaking
to the minister representing the
government this morning he says that
your teachers are being irresponsible
well he's completely wrong the
government is letting our children down
there is ongoing disruption every day in
our schools since covid they appointed
Kevin Collins as her recoveries are he
gave them a program that we agreed with
it would have cost them 14 billion
pounds they refused to do it they cut it
down to less than a third we are hearing
stories every day of special needs
assistance leaving jobs in schools to
work in supermarkets leaving children
without support every day of GCSE
classes being taught by somebody who
doesn't have a qualification doing their
best but being taught by somebody who
doesn't have a qualification in the
subject of primary classes where there
are successions of temporary teachers
because they can't hold on to permanent
teachers there's disruption every day in
our schools because the government isn't
investing in our schools or the people
who work in them
how appropriate is it though that
teachers are not sharing what their
plans are with head teachers so that
they can make plans for youngsters
tomorrow
well I think it's very appropriate you
know if this was the pandemic if it was
another natural phenomenon we would be
doing everything we could to make sure
schools were running as much as possible
but the point about tomorrow is that
it's a strike it's a strike because
we're in dispute with the government
we're in dispute about that disruption
that's happening every day in schools we
want our strike to be effective in order
to concentrate the government's mind
we've done everything the law requires
of us and the laws in this country are
extremely strict around trades unions so
head teachers know how many Neu members
at least they know how many Nu members
there were at this when we when we
notified them the number has gone up
quite a lot actually but we've given
that information to heads that's the
information that's required of us
actually do you know most head teachers
are supporting the that their unions are
in the same position of being in dispute
with the government about these
questions and they want the action to be
successful they want the pressure to be
on government to change so that things
get better for the children in our
schools
so what do you hope to achieve by not
telling head teachers what you plan
well as I've just said we hope that we
want our strike to be effective tomorrow
in order to concentrate government's
mind we're in dispute the next day of
strike action is February the 28th we're
hoping to we're hoping to avoid that
next day of strike action we're hoping
to avoid the next day of strike action
or after that on the 15th and 16th of
March we want the government to
concentrate and come to the table and
bring proposals that can help us resolve
the dispute by helping us ensure we have
enough teachers and special needs
assistants and Tas in our schools so
that education isn't disrupted every day
the way it is at the moment I understand
that Mr Courtney but I'm asking
specifically by not telling head
teachers what the plan is what do you
think will happen tomorrow
well head teachers should be planning on
the basis that Neu members are on strike
and we've given them that information
and they can plan on that basis
but it could mean that some Neu members
go in some don't some kids might get to
school and then be turned around and
sent back again what what I don't
understand
well I don't think that will be the case
in very many situations lots of schools
will have made a decision to close some
will be keeping some classes open
because some teachers will have told the
head that they're going to in in school
on that day but the whole point of this
is to put pressure on government to come
to the table so we can stop the
disruption in schools that's happening
every day we want our strike to be
effective it's not the same as a natural
phenomenon where we would be like kovid
where we would be doing everything we
could to make sure that schools were
running as well as possible we are in
dispute we are on strike our members are
giving up their days pay for a noble
Purpose By the way of trying to you know
improve education by improving the
funding and the pay of the people who
work in our schools but they're giving
up their pay for a noble purpose we want
their sacrifice to be effective we want
government to feel that they have to
talk to us so that there isn't another
strike on February the 28th March the
1st March the 2nd March the 15th 16th
the dates that we've identified we want
to avoid those strikes and that means we
want this strike to be as effective as
possible
why did the talks fail yesterday
well because uh because the minister
brought no proposals whatsoever to the
table there are nothing whatsoever on
pay this year or next year no suggestion
of a non-consolidated lump sum no
suggestion of a pay rise on the other
hand we took to her a comprehensive set
of data from bodies that aren't unions
pointing to the relative decline in
teacher pay since 2010 as a real problem
for Recruitment and Retention we took a
paper by Luke simbietta for the ifs
suggesting that teacher pay has dropped
while average pay in the economy has
increased we took a paper by public
first the right of Center Think Tank
which says that teachers and social
workers have suffered the worst during
this period of wage suppression we took
a chart from the Sunday time saying the
same we took information that we'd got
um that we developed that the financial
times run with showing a sharp decline
in in teacher pay compared with average
compared with the the sort of averages
in other professions since 2010 those
things really matter to teach a
recruitment and retention we took in the
report from the national foundation for
Education research which says the
government's pay proposals will not
solve the problem on teacher Recruitment
and Retention okay it's good to talk to
Mr Courtney um let's see if any
last-ditch talks could um fend off this
strike tomorrow unlikely oh he's gone
there we are now the Princess of Wales
has launched a new campaign to shine a
spotlight on the importance of early
childhood a warning this report from our
Royal correspondent Rihanna Mills
contains flash photography
now Princess of Wales this is Kate
showing you what she wants to do with
that title launching a new campaign
called shaping us to make us all wake up
to the importance of those Early
Childhood years
during this time we lay the foundations
and building blocks for life
it is when we learn to understand
ourselves
understand others and understand the
world in which we live
this is why it is essential
to not only understand the unique
importance of our earliest years
but to know what we can all do to help
raise future generations of happy
healthy adults
they're hoping this video brings it to
life showing how from birth to five a
child is shaped by their contact not
just with their parents but others like
teachers or family friends
[Music]
okay
a message that celebrity ambassadors are
helping them to spread it's quite a lot
of thread to put on
you know and
have children and we'll raise them to
the best of our ability but actually
they're saying it takes a village is
really true
for over a decade Kate's been learning
about how much those early years can
impact things like mental health
problems or addiction as an adult but
when families are struggling enough for
their heating or food Bills or the
campaign really cut through I hope so
because that is exactly why it is
relevant at the moment because it's
exactly those kind of pressures that are
impacting parents today so this campaign
is about how do we help parents how do
we support them as individuals and as
communities
the media's obsession with how she looks
can at times overshadow what Kate has
got to say but we're told that she sees
this as the start of a vital
conversation with the nation we now wait
to see if people really listen and want
to do something about it
Rhiannon Mills Sky News
while the U.S Secretary of State that's
Anthony blinken of course he has urged
both Israel and Palestine to de-escalate
violence and restore security the region
is experiencing the worst violence in
years 20 years now is the Israeli
ambassador to the United Kingdom Valley
is that how I pronounce yes it's nice to
see you good morning joining us how are
you going to de-escalate the violence
first of all good morning I'm so happy
to be here with you for the opportunity
to speak about what was going on the
weekend in Israel we had a very
difficult weekend because unfortunately
on Friday night when people were going
out of a synagogue you know Shabbat is
the holiday in our week and they went
from the synagogue to go and have their
nice Friday night dinner they were
attacked by a Palestinian terrorists
firing with gun killing seven people
um some of the people I think people
were heartbroken when they the sort of
faces of Usher was a 14 year old young
boy and a nice couple Natalie and Ellie
that just got married two years ago and
they came to help the people that were
injured and unfortunately the terrorist
was so cruel that he was shutting them
and and that that was the weekend we
went through and when uh when that
happened President Biden called right
away to prime minister Netanyahu he said
this is horrific
um we we are supporting your right for
self-defense and so uh did the foreign
Secretary of the UK James cleverly that
said that on the international day when
we memorized the Holocaust such horrific
sides coming from Jerusalem is something
that nothing can justify you know
harming innocent people so that was a
very very difficult weekend okay
um a father shot dead in front of his
son at a makeshift check point two weeks
ago Israeli soldiers saying he had a
knife later admitted he was unarmed
um there is violence on both sides how
are you going to sort it out
so um it's not violence on both sides it
seems pretty violent so the way we see
it
um Israel is under attack under
terrorism and what we do is in order to
defend ourselves the government is
um committed to defend its people we
don't want people to be shot when they
walk in the streets so This Is Our
obligation so when we do military
actions like we did the defense actions
in Janine last week it's because we had
intelligence alert on another terror
attack That was supposed to come from
Janine Janine became a terror Hub
unfortunately the Palestinian Authority
is at the moment one of its weakness
points where they cannot do anything so
this creates a vacuum and this Terror
hops need to be controlled and in order
to control that in order to defend
people not to have more terror attacks
in our streets we send our defense
verses in order to make sure that those
kind of Terror attacks won't be a daily
thing your interior minister is a
convicted racist and is Extreme views
towards Palestinians but is now in
charge of police and policing them what
faith should the International Community
have in that
well the Israeli Supreme Court makes the
decision who's racist and is not and it
was very clear when he was running to
office to go into the knesset that the
Israeli Supreme Court says that on the
base of his Manifesto is not under this
definition so first of all I don't agree
with the description but if we go back
policing the Palestinians and he has
extreme views about them but if we go
back to the Israeli government the
Israeli government is a coalition
government something that in the UK is
not something you have many times I mean
you're used to different type of systems
got to do with his views on on Palestine
I explained because his views on
Palestinian have been under review under
judicial review of our Supreme Court and
the Supreme Court said very clearly that
he put one thing in his Manifesto which
is safety in The Straits of Israel and
this is why he was elected so I just
don't agree with the description but if
we go back to the government the
government is being ruled by being
Benjamin netanyahu's party this is the
dominant party and fraud hanging over
him
this is something being checked in a
court and I think his leadership for the
last 20 years was dominanted by a vision
of creating more peace with our
neighbors as you know the Abraham
Accords is something that happened under
his leadership so in the last two years
we had more and more countries joining
to the peace Circle and actually the
visit of Anthony blinken yesterday one
of the main issues in this visit is hard
to extend a peace Circle and how to
bring Saudi Arabia into the circle how
to make sure that the region will be
more safe so I really think that this is
a good role model about Israel and our
world can create great things together
because the Abraham Accords is being
wonderful success
okay talk to me about why you would
bring um gun licenses why are you
loosening gun licenses for Israelis how
is that not going to exacerbate the
situation so I'm very happy you're
asking about that because I don't know
if people are familiar with our very
very strict gun laws so Israel has a
very strict gun laws and what the
government is doing is basically
allowing just the people that already
have a license people that are trained
are well trained or part of security and
Defense Forces just to carry their guns
in order to you know prevent this
horrific kind of uh you know terrible
and shoot somebody we're not going to
hand out guns I mean just to make it
sure and clear you've got a gun you're
gonna you only have a gun to shoot
somebody no but we have guns in order to
defend ourselves many people in Israel
as you know we have how do you defend
yourself
no just to explain how the Israeli
system works we have a very strict gun
loans and the people that are allowed to
carry guns are people that are trained
in our security systems because many
people as you know in Israel work on
security work so part of the work of
those security people is if something
horrific like happened Friday night is
happening is to protect the people so
this is part of their Duty or their
civil duty but we are not handing over
guns and the Prime Minister said it very
clearly no one is taking the Law into
his hands we have policing forces and we
have Defense Forces in order to do that
no one is encouraging violence actually
we want to de-escalate so normal
civilians will not be getting guns
absolutely not okay
what is actually happening then when we
you are relaxing the gun laws what does
that actually mean it's not really
relaxing gun laws it's more the people
that are already trained and they're
able that they will be encouraged to
carry those guns in order to protect
people sometimes they take the police
people not to shoot people to protect
people if they're under terror attack
and just to go back to our history so
many times in our history including by
the way the mayor of Jerusalem that was
involved in a middle of a scene of
terrorism so he had to run after a
terrorist when he was firing and
shooting people in the streets of
Jerusalem so unfortunately because
Israel has such a bad experience with
terrorism in our streets sometimes
people that carry guns because they are
part of security and Defense Forces they
actually saved lives so we're not
speaking in any way on something that is
um you know handing over there has to be
peace otherwise we will continue to see
the death toll rise talk to me about the
importance of taking the houses from the
families of those that are caught up in
terrorism what's the point of that um
first of all let's start with what you
started there must be peace so why there
is no peace if Israel is doing so well
with Egypt with Jordan we have a proven
record of a country that seeks peace in
one's peace so why is it so hard with
our neighbors the Palestinians and I
think some of the answer comes from the
horrible incitement that brings a 13
year old boy to take a gun and as you
said to shot a father and a son one
after the other a 13 year old boy can
you imagine a 13 year old boy anywhere
else in the world taking a gun firing
trying to kill innocent people I think
it's very Insight demolish his family's
home again so the reason we're doing it
is in order to discourage uh the other
people to be involved with terrorism
just not just the child's responsibility
it's the whole family that is
responsible the way we see it the way we
see it it's not the feminist
responsibility or any we see it as look
at what is happening with the
Palestinian Authority delivering
financial support to everyone who's
involved with terrorism there is so much
incentive under the Palestinian
leadership to be involved with terrorism
they actually delivered
trying to disincentivize other families
by demolishing the homes of those we
make sure that people will understand
that they need to pay a price for
terrorism because at the moment the only
price they're getting is rewards from
the Palestinians is it the whole
family's responsibility we're saying
again this is not a punishment for the
for the for the Family itself
because you need to take responsibility
for the fact that your Palestinian
Authority is actually giving you this
motivation to go and kill innocent Jews
in the streets I mean this is a pure
anti-Semitism think about it if someone
would have taken a gun here in London
would have shut juice just because there
are Jews the whole country would have
been in headlines saying this is
horrific this is anti-Semitism in Israel
in in some very strange way people are
saying no well you need to understand
the circumstances nothing can justify
hurting innocent people and this is
what's happening on both sides I suppose
but again we don't hurt innocent people
well does it as I just pointed out to
you we don't Target innocent people um
at a checkpoint and he was unarmed in
front of his child
that actually it's not correct because
we never Target innocent people never
Israel is doing everything in order to
Target terrorists and this is what we
need to do in order to make sure that
our streets will be peaceful what would
be a good result when Anthony blinker
gets back on the plane to go back to
America so there are three issues that
he came to discuss first is uh
Palestinian terrorism and I think part
of it is again to make sure the
leadership of the Palestinian will will
be taken into account for those horrible
incitements and the fact they're
celebrating when Jews being killed 30
seconds the second issue is Iran I think
this is the most important and extending
the circle of Peace so I think all
together I think it will be very
successful will extend circle of peace
and will continue to do the great work
we do on Iran we just had the biggest
exercise between Israeli defend forces
and American defend forces last week out
of time thank you your Excellency for
joining us I really appreciate hopeful
peaceful days yeah absolutely thank you
good to see you thank you for joining us
on the program this morning bear with me
one second if you would please coming up
in just a few moments time uh we'll be
actually tomorrow in interviewing the
Palestinian ambassador to the UK Hashem
genlot and I will be asking him what
he's going to do for peace
[Music]